I don't know about everyone else, but I am just,
just bouncing around here with excitement.
And I hoping now that Kate Hoey is going to bring us down to us.
Kate is going to be speaking against the motion.
Kate former Labour and Pete 30 years distinguished service
born in Northern Ireland, served and Tony Blair's government,
independent minded, Kate. She defied the labor whip on,
as you heard banning books ending and against the Iraq war.
And she was a leading campaigner for leave in the referendum.
Kate.
Thank you. And it is a pleasure to be here,
and I hope that I'm going to actually cheer you all up after that
slightly depressing speech by my ex constituent, um,
Mr. Self, uh, mind you,
he's never been so miserable that he had to come and see me about any problems.
So that's fine.
And it's lovely to be on the same stages on the opposite side as, as,
um, Peter Hitchens, because Peter and I share,
I think I'll share a little secret that I think we both,
it's not really a secret. We were both trots in a long time ago and, uh,
we, we, um,
we have moved as you can see politically now it is a great pleasure to be here,
and I'm very proud tonight to speak up for my country and I'm making it very
clear.
I'm speaking up for the United Kingdom because great Britain excludes Northern
Ireland and Northern Ireland of course is one of the best parts of the United
Kingdom.
And I want to say just very clearly at the beginning,
I'm very patriotic. I love my country. I cherish being British.
I cherish being able to be a citizen of this country
and I get quite emotional. I'll be honest too.
When I see the union flag being raised and I hear
the national Anthem being played and I'm not ashamed of that.
And I don't think any of us should be, but of course tonight,
we don't have to prove on this side that the United Kingdom is the greatest
country in the world. The question really is, are we one of the great countries?
And it really isn't a value judgment either on,
regarding a country. I don't think there's any kind of, uh, nationalist,
uh, exaggeration to regard a country, which has had a profound influence,
whatever will may have said on the entire course of history as a great one.
And of course, importantly, grit is not a value judgment,
meaning good. Uh, China's a great country,
but I would very much detest its political system. Uh,
Russia could be considered to be a great country and we mustn't forget that it
was British people who wrote the constitution of one of the greatest countries
in the, in the world. And they certainly think they are anyway,
the United States of America.
And when we then go to look at this, to me,
absolutely fundamental to this whole debate is that we
are a great democracy from at least the
13th century, uh,
on there have been efforts and campaigns and Wars to reign in the powers
of government and to establish the primacy of the rule of law.
And our greatest claim to greatness I believe is that we have created a fiercely
democratic society that treasures the liberties,
our ancestors fought for and died for over many,
many centuries. And we have seen,
I know we probably don't want to talk about it,
but we have seen a great example of that.
Recently our political system delivered a
referendum result that most of our political leaders and the
dominant intellectual academic and legal class have been
unable to stop. And they certainly tried to stop it.
And the people showed that they were prepared to actually give quite
a beating to a party that had tried to stop that
referendum result. Our country is one of the most free,
open and tolerant societies in the world and a welcoming country,
whatever anyone says to outsiders and perhaps that's why
people from all over the world, living in oppressed countries,
living under dictatorships, living as, as,
as in Wars torn countries,
dream of still coming to this country as a refuge.
And if we look at what's happening at the moment in the English channel,
why are all those little boats filled with migrants?
Most of them with no relatives here whatsoever,
why are they coming from a safe country, France to the British shore?
Our sense of freedom, fairness, and justice,
and of the opportunities our society offers of building a new life
free from fear that's,
what's bringing them British greatness extends of course,
far beyond the British eyes. And this is where I feel very strongly.
We belong to a global family of nations, unlike any other,
the Commonwealth,
a creation of genius expressing the sense of tolerance and shared
values championed by her majesty the queen throughout her
Rian, still countries with only slender connections to our,
to the United Kingdom are queuing up to join this remarkable
reinvention of a worldwide empire,
which we had as a free association of independent yet
interdependent nations committed to work together even more
closely than friends, but as family.
And I hope that we will win ti and I'm sure everyone on this platform,
hopefully we'll maintain friendship with all the EU countries,
but they're not our family,
our place at the head of the 53 nations of the Commonwealth,
nearly 3 billion people.
One third of the world's population is an asset.
We should be proudly celebrating and we tend to take it for granted yet these
days yet.
So many nations can only dream of such a wellspring of Goodwill and
positive engagement trading with countries that use our system of law,
our language, and base their institutions, professions,
their parliaments and systems of government on our model.
Other nations, look to the United Kingdom again,
whatever are the movers of this motion will say,
other nations do still look to us for leadership.
And of course with greatness comes that extra
responsibility,
but we have a soft power influence around the world that you could
not simply make up. It is there. And it dolls
ladies and gentlemen,
this so much great about the United Kingdom,
that it's impossible to get into it in such a short time.
And I know that side,
so deed Willie will be putting some of the other points,
but of course being a great country doesn't mean that we're always right
and that we do the right things. And of course,
one of them has been mentioned was when we went into the Iraq war,
but we have a democracy and we can oppose it.
We can oppose things like that that are wrong.
And we don't have to like some of the things that governments do.
We don't have to like governments, whatever their political ideas are,
but we are a country also.
And I think this is very important when we're talking to perhaps other
countries, we are a country of foibles.
We do have some strange, strange customs. Um,
one of those customs, which in tears,
I think visitors to us is our queuing habit.
Another one is the way we repeatedly say, sorry,
I walked from Victoria to Westminster the other day.
And I just deliberately counted the number of times that I actually said,
sorry on that walk.
And it's amazing how often we just automatically say, sorry,
and it's something that we, as a country, we can put ourselves down. We,
we never, actually, we always try to underestimate things.
We never exaggerate. We shouldn't exaggerate,
but politicians are always exaggerating. But I would say that we,
we on the whole, our, our, our makeup is that we don't, we understand ourselves,
we don't blow enough of our own trumpet as a country.
And of course we have a Monarch that even will,
might agree with actually uses tubberware. So we, we have, we have,
uh, we have a way of showing that we are not too full of ourselves.
No other country can present such a long list of credentials.
Uh, but I, but I think still, uh,
that our best days are ahead.
And I want to just also to say very quickly as a former sports minister,
you know, sport has sole important in the world, particularly to young people.
And those many of the sports of that have been right across the
world. We put the rules there,
we set the boundaries and now, and again, we still actually win.
And one of the points that I actually think is just very interesting to point
out that of the 10 teams in formula one,
racing seven are based in the United Kingdom.
We have a premier league of football.
That's watched the biggest one watched by more people all over the world.
We came second in the, in the Olympics in Rio.
We came second in the Paralympics, which we started at stoke Mandeville.
And of course we've got wonderful golfers, like Rory McIlroy.
I would mention him. And then we've got Eddie, the Eagle.
And it's that contrast that shows what a great country we are.
So let us not be full of doom and gloom.
I want to see the next decade of one of hope,
optimism and ambition using the creativity of all our peoples.
So banish the two mongers throughout this motion and celebrate all that is
great about this grit country.
[Inaudible].
So after depressive for yest, well,
we've had emotional foil bullish Kate,
and now we're going to go on to Peter Hitchins
member of the international socialists,
not now until 1975.
[Inaudible].